[Music]
all right Azhar thank you for being with
us thank you for being my this evening
of course of course 12,000 kilometers
not keeping us apart even in terms of
Corona absolutely okay in doing so
Parliament member and former VC and a
CEO and entrepreneur and social
entrepreneur and all-around incredible
leader one of the best that I know it's
not gonna do justice if they even start
to talk a bit about about what you did
can you can you share a little bit about
some of the things that you've done over
the past several dozen years and some of
the things that excite you you know I
started my career as a as an electronics
engineer and then moved on it's what
kind of capacities I think that my most
exciting times were spent as an
entrepreneur I enjoyed very much taking
ideas into product into customers hands
into building a business around him
which I did a number of times two of
them were with the adventure backs
companies that I had the privilege of
running both of them realized successful
investors but that was not the main
issue the main point was really seeing
your product in the hands of customers
and positively influencing people around
the world which was a lot of excitement
a lot of fun and you know self rewarding
in terms of satisfaction and pride you
know all the older things that I guess
motivate us individuals and so I did
that and then I joined and venture
capital firm in the u.s. called Cana
partners I was one of a team of ten
people most times were we invested in
companies mostly in the US but also in
Israel and in India and that was
exciting as well this time taking a back
seat as a board member as an investor
hopefully sometimes as a value-add
mr. I had a lot of fun and this was also
rewarding in a sense of having the
chance of working with very talented
bright people around the world on
bringing their ideas into ba into market
seem to influencing positively people
around the world which is again a lot of
fun a lot of satisfaction and you know
it was also and educating journey just
because you meet with so many bright
people with so many great ideas and you
only can join some of them on the
journey but that was very exciting as
well so you know I did all kind of
interesting things I guess the last a
year plus we can speak about as well if
you want so okay so doing it so
interesting things I think that's
putting it a little bit mildly and we'll
get to that but as of last year you're a
kinetic member and you're now serving
the public serving Israel and you're
influencing in ways that are very
different from the way an entrepreneur
or a venture capitalist can and it
sounds like a pretty interesting
transition moving from high-tech very
agile move fast and break things and
very capitalistic to all of a sudden
serving the public and and bringing up
bringing the social good in mind so why
why at age 55 are you now standing in
the Knesset and fighting for the good of
the Israeli citizens well you know one
day when I have the time to sit down and
write my memories I'll have to go back
to this specific question and try to
answer it properly
at this time I can only offer thoughts
you know because this is an ongoing
process I'm more than a year into this
it kind of happened all of a sudden
although I had been so to speak in
public service for quite some time you
know as a volunteer yes a venture
capitalist but
that aside as a volunteer Irene a
non-for-profit organization that dealt
with and still is dealing now without
paper dealt with your around the country
here in Israel coming from challenging
social and economic backgrounds so those
young adults were under the the great
support and care of our volunteers
around the country so I did start for
more than ten years a very hard as a
volunteer on integrating various people
into basically I take coming from your
work to the harmonies as well right
say that again you worked with the four
eighties as well quite a quite a bit so
yeah so I my point was trying to
integrate people who come from
communities we shall not necessarily
interpret it properly
today's really high-tech that way
integrating those people into the
high-tech father served the two main
causes one of them is just giving them
equal opportunities and providing them
with the appropriate platform to go
about their desires and and so improving
their economics but there was also a
bigger cause which was this is important
for the Israeli society you know
bringing people together from different
communities different backgrounds in
something is something that we are
missing badly over here so I did that
and then so you know at a certain point
in juncture I came across this
opportunity of joining the political
life which was a very tough decision
leaving all those exciting interesting
and fun lifestyles and and just you know
way of going about life that was a lot
of fun and very rewarding personally
and also you know the kind of life I
think I would be happy to go back one
day 20 30 years from now so I had to
leave all of this behind me and join the
the political arena but I think that I
did is because I understood that what I
did as a volunteer can scale up in a
significant way if I am willing to take
their responsibility and willing to turn
to take up on the challenge and my life
completely upside down from a private
entrepreneur and venture capitalists
becoming a public figure that's a hell
of a change I did this and then Here I
am I mean say you take a really
non-traditional approach or I mean a lot
of politicians they start they start in
politics from a very very junior
position and then they their dream is to
even hopefully one day become close to
being a Knesset member and you really
jumped into the ship of some really
really amazing people and over a year
fought for Fahd really for democracy as
the main stance more than anything and
now now you're talking about the
high-tech technology within government
now those two things don't make sense to
me
I mean when I think when you think of
government at least I guess up until my
generation a bit beyond you really you
you think of slow moving you think of
bureaucracy you think of it's all about
the budget for this and budget for that
and now you're coming in and saying
let's do it high tech what does that
mean can governments be agile can
government's pivot when they need to
Philippi
Wow you know you made this Michael right
to the point so you know it is a huge
challenge governments are slow very
bureaucratic huge operations in many
cases unnecessarily big and with so many
processes that kind of go against
innovation against agile approaches to
anything and then you go into this and
say I'm going to introduce change so yes
it is a huge challenge but this is part
of the transformation any nation
with emphasis on democratic nations they
have to go through so you know
technology has taken the world through a
significant breakthrough and we have all
seen the leap forward of changing the
way we run our lives personally on the
business side on the community side
everywhere around us governments are
still way behind a very slow to respond
but governments who wanted to survive
have to go through that transition you
know your generation will not be willing
to accept governments that slow down
your development to plan our development
desires the willingness to do stuff
quickly and efficiently it's a it's a
way of life right so here is a huge
challenge I think that I am in a good
position to realize but the need is
there that it is a critical need and we
have to start the transition so you know
I think that other people already
started this transition not only in
Israel but in other democracies like in
the US and elsewhere but there's a lot
to be done and I think that we are here
in Israel in a position in a good
position to try to push the things
forward because we are a startup nation
because there are so many technologies
breakthrough technologies that are being
developed here and because we are a
small country overall the positive nodes
the positive technology and innovation
noise has gone across just the high-tech
community so many people run the country
somehow and they study notion of
innovation and they also grew to to know
to demand better from the government
just because they see things managed
differently elsewhere and so this is
some sort of a turning point were people
around the country realized that a
change is needed a change is possible
we the politicians have the duty of
introducing those changes so let me give
you a number of examples we want to
provide a to provide a much agent
service to the public most of the
service where the government faces the
public in Israel and by the way is where
as well still requires many face to face
interactions many paper-based
interactions and sort of old-world ways
of running your business so you know my
vision is hopefully a number of years
from now by law all Israeli government
officers and the authorities will be
required to have an electronic interface
with anybody who requires so you know I
have my parents there are 80 plus years
old they want to interface
person-to-person and that's totally fine
but your generation you know you will
probably find it hard to believe that
you need to go somewhere you need to
file a paper you need to interface with
a clarity it's it's really unacceptable
and there's no reason for that so we
have to go through that transition I
should say that a number of these
offices easily governmental offices have
started to go through that transition
but still there is a long way to go
luckily again we startup nation there's
so many technologies so many products
that have been developed over here to
improve the efficiency of processes to
provide better service to customers to
manage all kinds of processes in a much
better way so all of these interesting
enough is being sold outside of his
right just because he's really
entrepreneurs do not want to deal with
the government rightfully so I was in a
particular I have my scars of trying to
sell to the Israeli government so I know
what it takes but if you just improve
that face it of the government you
suddenly see the Israeli municipalities
are taking advantage of so many smart
cities technologies that have been
developed in Israel but are sold
exclusively elsewhere
of the country you see so many
technologies that can improve the
efficiency the productivity the security
of government agencies sold elsewhere
that can be integrated into our
government over here so that's an
example and I've just touched upon the
kind of the surface this is the trivial
right transition you know going
paperless going electronically and so on
but there is so many other layers that
one could think about and we have so
many good ideas but you know I could
spend the next 20 years or incubating
the ideas that would be a lot of fun
venture capitalists you're sitting and
and I have that I have the privilege now
of of experiencing a little taste of it
here here in Silicon Valley and I'm and
you know it's you sitting there and
you're trying to think of other business
proposition an opportunity to change
consumer behavior to improve the lives
of many and then you're sitting on your
side of the table is the venture
capitalist and trying to think is this
viable can I grow this into a scalable
business that will actually bring value
to people and I can't help but make the
comparison that you know sitting in the
position that you are now you're seeing
all these propositions all the time do
you find yourself ever putting on this
venture capitalist had and trying to
assess whether if this was a startup
that came and proposed would I believe
this this entrepreneur what I believe
this model that they're suggesting it's
an interesting analogy you know here's
something I learned every Parliament
member is actually some sort of a P&L
unit so really you know here in Israel
we have 120 Parliament members each of
whom makes decisions as to what to focus
on and what to invest their time in and
there are many opportunities to advance
all kind of laws all kind of public
services and one has to focus one has to
decide what is their specific advantage
what are their desires and what is that
you really want to promote you know
every day every day is a public place
ever
I get approached by many people who
rightfully so have all kind of
interesting ideas all kind of desires or
all kind of problems and you have to
make that decision you have to make that
decision of you know I want to focus on
certain areas I'm going to specialize in
those areas I want to provide service to
certain constituents and by doing this
by the way I realized that I give up
others so it's not an easy decision
pretty much the same way venture
capitalists works you know as the VC
partner I would see about 1,000
opportunities have year obviously as you
know I would have not been able to deal
with even one percent of them and if I
did two to three days a year I would
feel pretty good about it
right same here you know just to give
you a sense the previous full term
Knesset that worked in Israel was the
20th facility for it for about four
years and it was able to put together
about four hundred plus laws you know in
Israel but the number of law proposals
that were submitted were about 6000 law
proposals is for Poquette Co so here's
your ratio if you think about it is
about 6000 low proposals that were
filtered in not by visas but by twist
members so each of those basic members
probably looked at yeah at least 3 to 5
times that number and they decided to
narrow down to about 6000 low proposals
and four years later you see that about
400 or say like 7 8 percent of them were
really transacted so this is like taking
the VC approach and understanding each
and then kind of mapping it to to what
the process looks like in my life today
and frankly my life is a PCS absolutely
right I learned to prioritize to
understand where my added value stands
and to force myself to focus while
realizing that they may be keeping up
other opportunities as well and you
probably can't say to yourself but but
honestly it probably is the from the VC
perspective you also know sometimes to
cut the and
- and to get to the point and know some
of the things that go behind what's
what's actually behind the PowerPoint
presentation and I'm sure that that we
are a lot of value as well and this
combines if you want yeah of course
so you know these are Corona tines or
iris noise I should say and one of the
things we are one of the big challenges
we are facing as as the Parliament here
in Israel is the significant realistic
fear that sometime over the next few
days or few weeks we may find many of us
parliament members out of the Knesset
out of the parliament either being
instructed to stay home because we were
closed somebody who was affected
infected or one or some some of us may
be infected themselves so here's the
challenge the Israeli Parliament by a
very significant law we call them
foundation laws this is like the
Constitution translated into easily
terms we do not have a constitution here
but we have right basic laws that kind
of control the way we govern our
democracy one of these laws dictates
that any discussion and voting must take
in person in the Knesset if you are not
in deficit you're not allowed to vote
you're not allowed to have a to be part
of the discussion and interesting enough
throughout the 72 years of the Israeli
Parliament there was never a session
that was you know exhausted being being
handed because of anything so sometimes
there is a they used to be mergency
cases you know we were attached here
either so you stopped for 24 hours but
you continue the discussion and the
voting process so the democracy
continues to run but nobody ever thought
that you may find a situation where
people cannot go in person to do this
and by the way we have provisions of
substituting the requests of building
into some other building the whole kind
of the building so gathering
is possible but the notion of DVDs
electronically was never considered not
for technology reasons but just for you
could call this the basic democracy yeah
I want to see the in person so I used my
experience and submitted an urgent Lowe
proposal to the closet where we are kind
of running against time you know it
takes time versus law sometimes it takes
two to three years sometimes it takes a
few months it really takes a few days
while you're running again and so the
clock is ticking we submitted a law
proposal this week and we hope to be
able to bring it up to discussion on
Monday next week which is a
record-breaking pace and that law will
allow for a limited amount of time and
for very specific cases which are people
that have to be isolated by the orders
of the Ministry of Health although they
have been infected but they will be
allowed to log in electronically and
they will be allowed to discuss and to
vote which is a very significant
precedence we have both swirl the move
we set with top lawyers here in Israel
constitutional lawyers and others and we
have come up with the right formula that
kind of satisfies everybody and now
we're running against time the the real
fear is that we will not have enough
people to vote on submitting and
approaching and approving this low
before people are being isolated so
here's a combination of everything you
have the pizza aisle and ecology pie and
the Parliament member who are trying to
put all of this together very very
fascinating Wow well best of luck I mean
that I mean that's just inspiring to
hear from my end
he's out you have to go back to running
the country but a three words that
describe you well yeah
dreamer optimistic passionate I love it
is that thank you so so much love that
thank you
please take care stay healthy bye-bye